As many of you know, Donald Trump's personal
lawyer, Rudy Giuliani, has once again reentered
the spotlight because of his role in the recent
New York Post story.
More and more of which is being debunked daily.
And one of the speculations about Rudy Giuliani
for a while, it's been written about for a
long time.
Not something I came up with is that Rudy
has a serious drinking problem and that in
particular, there was an effort to keep Rudy
off of nighttime television because then it
was more likely that Rudy Giuliani would be
drunk.
And that, Yasha, the afternoons could be tough
because he would maybe have a few too many
with lunch, but that the nighttime was really,
really the problem.
Now, I won't go back through all of the archives,
but we've seen clips before of Rudy Giuliani
showing up, slurring one I have shot one day.
Half his hair was was like shaved.
He had, like, shaved half of his head.
Maybe it was just a coping issue.
Crooked glasses, shiny eyes, red eyes that,
you know, the entire thing.
Anyway, Donald Trump's other former lawyer,
Michael Cohen, went on MSNBC and straight
up said Rudy Giuliani is drunk all the time.
And it's not speculation.
It's based on what I meaning Michael Cohen
has seen.
Take a look at Rudy's recent drunk all the
time, which is a big problem.
And that's what makes him susceptible because
his faculties are gone.
He behaves crazy now as a journalist.
Ask you, are you sharing an opinion or are
you sharing an observation like you've seen
him drink X amount?
That's the same thing.
An investigator would like to see him drink
at a point like he's a high school drunk and
it makes him susceptible.
He takes the information that he gets.
He provides it to the president.
And simply because Rudy, who used to be considered
you know, he I mean, a real a real litigator
and he was considered to be America's mayor,
is now really just a joke.
The one thing there that we, of course, know
to be true is that Rudy Giuliani is now considered
to be a joke.
But that's not actually what's relevant here.
And to be really, really careful, this is
not ha ha.
Rudy is an alcoholic.
This is about yet another person who has a
direct line to Trump and is directing much
of the opposition stories trying to help Trump.
He is allegedly heavily influencing this.
And we are learning that his state of mind
and actions may be affected by drugs that
make you make bad decisions.
If you go to counterintelligence one to one,
one of the things any good operative knows
is when an individual would be susceptible
to alcohol.
Other substances to disinhibit them in ways
that could be advantageous to an adversary
if you're working a target.
You would, of course, know this.
Rudy admits that it's a 50 percent chance
he was working with a Russian spy on the old.
The eventual New York Post story.
We know Rudy was a big factor in pushing for
the story to be published, despite the hesitations
that we learned about yesterday.
Thanks to The New York Times by New York Post
staffers who were saying that I don't think
we should even be publishing this.
This is exactly how people get taken advantage
of by professionals.
Now, the counter to this would be let's not
just say it's alcohol's fault.
Rudy Giuliani is a wealthy, privileged man
with a working brain who is choosing not only
to work for Trump, but to continue working
for Donald Trump.
And while the individual action might be affected
maybe by his alcohol consumption.
If you believe what Michael Cohen says, that,
you know, Giuliani has agency here and he
is a willing participant.
Rudy Giuliani's daughter, who is supporting
Joe Biden, has written about Rudy is choosing
to do this.
You can't just say it's the alcohol.
It can be both.
That, Judy, that Rudy, rather, is, of course,
complicit, but open to being taken extra advantage
of because of the drinking that many now have
alleged.
Also interesting, by the way, from that interview
I showed you is from an Ari Melber interview
on MSNBC.
One of the other things that Michael Cohen
said is that Chris Christie's debate prep
for Trump included suggesting trigger Biden's
stutter by interrupting a lot.
It'll make Biden's stutter and he will look
bad.
This has been denied by Chris Christie.
Seems totally plausible.
And it is it is merely an allegation.
But as far as the drunkenness thing, if Michael
Cohen were making this up, Rudy could sue
him.
And Rudy is not going to sue him.
And there's every indication Michael Cohen
is telling the truth, because that's what
anybody who's seen Rudy on TV, particularly
the nighttime appearances, would suspect.
More sad than anything is.
I mean, listen.
Alcoholism is a health issue.
What's particularly sad is that individuals
who may be in vulnerable states because of
their substance abuse are being deputized
to drive main narratives, primary narratives
in the Trump smear campaign against Joe Biden.
And that's that that's pretty ugly stuff.